[MUSIC PLAYING]
I'm Leo Villareal.
I'm an artist based in New York.
And I've created a piece called
Light Matrix (MIT) that's
installed for the Sloan School.
This piece consists of a
matrix of stainless steel rods.
There are 240 rods total.
So it's a three
dimensional array.
And each rod has 72 white
LEDs embedded in it.
And I have 255 levels
of brightness per LED.
The other important
component is the software.
There's a tool that
we've been working on
for over 10 years that's custom
designed to create sequences.
So I'm gathering
those sequences,
and then combining them into
more elaborate compositions.
And in the end,
those sequences are
displayed in a random order
for a random amount of time.
I've been here working on
the fine tuning of the piece.
It's site specific.
So it's very important for
me to be here, you know,
get a sense of the place.
So I'm looking at the
ambient light levels,
the level of activity to find
the right tempo and brightness.
So it's really like--
almost like tuning
a musical instrument.
Working with light is--
I mean, it's so primal.
Light is a very
seductive material,
so people are drawn to it.
We have this deep, as humans,
this very deep response to it.
So I'm interested in
the hypnotic qualities
and, you know, when you're
staring into a campfire.
Tapping into that, I think,
is very powerful and something
that you can't decode either.
I'm playing with the
compulsion pattern recognize.
You start to recognize
something but then
it changes and becomes
something else.
It's a little bit of a game, and
that you're putting information
out there that's
not quite complete.
But this whole process,
I think, is somehow
pleasurable to look at
and to spend time with.
MIT's always been a sort of
mythological place for me.
And I've visited here many
times and been so inspired.
So it's a really
great honor to be here
and to work within this context.
I'm interested in the
livability of the piece,
creating something that
can fit within the fabric
of the architecture of
the clause of the building
and be something that really
contributes to people's lives
on campus.
And yeah.
So we'll see what happens.